[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma été quel est le menu
du jour aujourd'hui on va faire de la
morue de la mort on en mange presque
plus jamais autrefois aimé oui parce
qu'autrefois c'était le pas des pauvres
riz et maintenant ça commence à être du
luxe parce que les tricheurs
oui elle devient très celle de niamey
comme un sérieux coup et ben voilà les
dents savoir pourquoi j'en sais rien on
dit que nos cousins un portugais en
mangent énormément c'est leur plat
national
oui même qu'elle va peut-être ça qui
fait monter un petit peu les boules je
pensais quand même faut pas rêver non je
pense pas mais les très chers toute
façon même s'il la trouve votre chéri e
aussi en marche moins bien sûr c'est
devenu un peu un plat plus luxueux oui
alors maïté on peut la commander de bien
des façons une rue qu'est ce que vous
nous proposez et bien aujourd'hui à
faire tout simplement de la brandade de
morue et une la morue parce que très
bien alors là nous avons la chance d'en
avoir deux ans - parce que celle là
c'est vanessa lui elle est salée c'est
comme ça qu'on la voit revenir de
terre-neuve
lorsque je crois que c'est là bas qu'il
appelle j'étais arrivé à dire maintenant
il faut la conserver sur le bateau et
depuis vous savez que j'ai eu 2
alexandre d'humeur qu'on fait comme ça
depuis le 9e sied pas dit dans ces vieux
et j'ai aussi lu que vous savez au
xvième siècle la france envoyait plus de
1000 bateaux péchés du côté de
terre-neuve le maurupt mais ne sont plus
à bordeaux il n'y a plus de me recruter
mais il ya un quartier qui s'appelle le
quartier de bacalan parce que battre les
anglais c'est quoi je veux le poisson
ces bacchanales
c'est le nom de la marque voilà la morue
en patois
alors le quartier de bacalan ces deux
quartiers de la morue mais
malheureusement il n'y a plus de brut y
j'ai aussi lu que c'était l'animal non
seulement le plus vorace mais le plus
fait qu un bouton et une aux grosses
morue figurez vous qu'elle peut faire 9
millions de la pauvre heureusement ils
viennent pas tous ce jour 1500 ça comme
ils disent et aussi l'atlantique triple
et on ne traverserait à pied si tous
leurs oeufs
arrivé avec l'os et le serait moins cher
peut-être me suis montrée bien voilà
alors nous avons la chance d'en avoir
une fraîche une fraîche c'est assez rare
de les voir comme ça un cabillaud
d'ailleurs là avec moi personnellement
je n'avais pas trouvé
elle n'a pas sa tête mais enfin quand
même sa boîte et le joli bon alors vous
allez nous faire
la recette de la brandade oui donc de la
morue basque qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
ces deux recettes bon alors d'abord pour
la morue basque oui d'amaury basque il
faut du jambon il faut pas de ça il faut
de leur union il faut et piment du thym
du laurier des tomates et du de ces
petits piments d'une bonne petite
persillade et la morue sèche et la morue
salée
voilà ça l'est et pour la brande ali
nous faudra coin pour la ramade et nous
faut du lait et des pommes de terre en b
pas tout seul à l'ailé des pommes de
terre de la persillade nôtres morue
c'est à dire persia delahaye beaucoup de
volailles et de l'huile d'olive et de
l'huile d'olive
bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en
premier il faut la faire baisser les
c'est habile c'est à dire on la met dans
l'eau 48 heures la peau en l'air pour
que le ciel tombe toujours parce
qu'autrement la peau l'empêchent pas de
tomber et il faut charger l'eau souvent
très souvent très souvent très souvent
très souvent pourquoi le sel sans âge
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup comme
le seul est imprégné la chair et le
savent et ne restent pas bon et à la
poule à faire à la biche cayenne qu'est
ce qu'il faudra faire en premier eh ben
il faut faire les petits légumes alors
là je commence à faire réduire de
l'oignon oui voilà oui il a commencé à
fond et donc il a commencé comme ça vous
l'avez fait réduire dans quoi dans
l'huile d'olive
il faut donner du goût du jour voilà
alors là est sauvé et casey de live
maintenant je les écraser on m'avait
déjà dit vous les écraser pour que ça
donne beaucoup de jeu il sait bien
meilleur jus c'est mieux et puis là du
moment qu'il faut que ça faut donner
voir avec l'amour il faut pas mal
d'habitués dans ce jeu vous l'enlever
parce que l'amour est plus à l'aise
c'est tout rires oui en option dont le
père des bonnes choses avaient voilà peu
fade alors on suit après je vais mettre
mes petits morceaux de jean board là
alors c'est du jambon de pays bien
désert dont deux pays bien sec que j'en
compte chez vous oui des primaires
et même s'il est un peu la salle aucune
importance ni comme un acteur meilleur
que vous allez coupé fin
d'où ils coupent pas mal aussi
savard ise attention doit on pas de
cette fois natale pour faire elle n'a
pas voulu venir
elle restera là voilà ça y est c'est pas
pour rien voilà alors je vais mettre ses
petits l'art d'ordre là dedans
après je vais couper les poivrons
je vous donne le gros poisson pour
commencer là oui oui je vais enlever les
graines
bien sûr c'est pas terrible et vous
allez le couper en lanières ou un
morceau est intervenu parce que vous en
savez d'hui oui d'ailleurs il faut que
tous à fond pendant très longtemps oui
de la compote de l'excellent travail ils
pouvaient tout doucement tout doucement
tout cela y va fort est-ce que vous
pouvez aussi un peu de piment forte des
réprimandes internet attire sans leur
donner du goût oui beaucoup plus que
celui ci parce que sa dette si beaucoup
plus tôt et l'ours est même plus fort
voilà ça valait tant pas fou commander
ici
voilà le fort là je laisse les graines
pourquoi pourquoi fait part que donne un
bouclier nous tout redonner du goût à la
graine dans l'orne
encore un autre race est réservé aux
arrivées l'approbateur et puis ça y est
la yole amis tomates que vous avez fait
pelé avant oui pour l'attraper dont nous
devions sur la mairie et puis ça y est
et puis c'est bon je vais laisser la
loire jeux récents et poivrer gentiment
pas trop voilà ça dans trois d'entre eux
portait un gros puisque ça va favoriser
la pompe sert leroy et le teint on
navigue à vue
on hamm est pas vous ne mettrez pas on
arrête pas là on ne met l'italie
lauriers bon voilà et je trouve on
couvre je pouvais et on est surtout un
petit ce très longtemps jusqu'à ce que
ça soit vraiment comme une confiture
alors pendant ce temps on va voir ce que
je vais m'occuper de la morue voulait
faire que tout autre et bien sûr que non
mais je suis rassuré quant à la non non
non non j'ai mis dans la poêle du
d'olive avec les gousses d'ail pelées
pour que ça donne un petit peu de goût à
l'huile oui alors je vais sentir ses
effets de taille
oui rien de mal en plus qui
non il faut pas qu'ils brûlent mais il a
donné samedi courageux mais pas côté
après ensuite vous allez coupé de la
morue découpé de la morue sait faire ça
c'est dur a coupé par ailleurs les a
fait un beau salaire très facile quand
on vous le voit faire un nom mais je le
coupe en deux oui on va faire de jolis
morceaux et qu'ils arrêtent me lis trop
vite
et puis je vais mettre ça dans la poêle
ingrandes c'est chaud et oui quand l
attention si vous allez va mettre les
deux gros format était la meilleure au
grand galop oui pour faire un petit
filet l'a pas trop grand voile voyez
comme ça on pourra que séduire quelques
fois ça y est voilà voilà mettre à cuire
moi j'adore l'adoré vous vouliez que je
vais te muter à tout à l'heure
eh bien je me demandais ne viendrait pas
qu'on aimerait c'est agréable de trouver
un bel goûte à la douleur mais je les
restes découverts
parce que je vais bientôt la morue je
vais retourner cette morue parce qu'il
faut juste pas le faire dorer un petit
peu c'est juste qu'on va sévir dans
l'huile d'olive au sein de la highway
and tag parfait voilà maintenant je vais
remettre damas purée ça le temps dans ce
produit de légumes oui là c'est
merveilleux
en fait ce qu'on voulait jolie en tout
cas il serait pas très très bon et
poursuivis ils vont trouver une recette
de idol reconnaître ce line up
voilà là et vous couvrez et je vais
recouvrir le tout et on va laisser
mijoter encore à bomber normes
exactement le temps ne peux pas le dire
parce que ça il faut tâter pour voir
comment ça c'est un faux cul garder
alors ça nous est peut-être le temps
quand même de faire la brandade on va
faire le bonheur de nous j'ai fait la
purée de pommes de terre gravier la
vraie alors maintenant je vais mettre un
filet d'huile pas pu parce que c'est
lourd mais les bien coloré c'est l'huile
d'olive évidemment bien sûr ah oui
toujours
toujours dans la brandade de lui je
remue après je prends ma mort eut alors
on l'a fait cuire comment alors l'eau à
l'oncle allopass aller parce qu'elle est
quand même encore un peu salines oui
voilà je vais enlever le plus d'arrêts
de possibles
enlevez la peau voilà savez la
fourchette
c'est pas la peine la voilà des mois
nous avons très bien parfait bien alors
ça suffit
je crois très bien on va montrer comment
on fait avec un enjeu écrase tout c'est
de la mort l'assiette comme ça aussi
romain oui je me remets cette morue là
dedans rich auteurs possibles sans
arêtes
il y en a quand même c'est pas le filet
de morue qu'on achète et c'est là
vraiment rue oui alors on enlève tout ce
qu'on peut mais si l'arrêt cet empire
inca faire attention quand on le mange
exactement on remue tout ça oui je vais
y rajouter la persillade qui va donner
un sacré bond avec hachis d'ail et le
père voilà bien
ne soyez pas raté un seul truc que ça va
bien deux monstres avaient repris là et
c'est tout et c'est fini que le bus eu
finalement c'est assez simple à faire
c'est très âpre et non c'est fini à
préparation mais oui je mets ça dans un
plat qui va au four y voilà je l'état
égalise oui pour que ça fasse
aujourd'hui ils avaient préparé un four
très chaud
ah oui il y en a qui mettent de la
chapelure y en a qui mettent du gruyère
à votre bon goût mais ces dames louant
dans la nature voyant four pour combien
de temps jusqu'à signer en jeu gratuit
n'est juste voilà terminèrent cinq
minutes ont passé mais oui et alors et
notre nouveau fait nos deux paires de
brusson fait alors c'est à dire que
celle là la brandade qui a passé cinq
minutes au four pour juste pour dorer
parce qu'il faut pas la faire sécher
elle a pris un petit coup de soleil
surtout de soleil on peut leur faire un
peu plus sa maman je ne vois rien de
plus facile à faire que ça monticule
m'en servir
c'est bon c'est simple à faire c'est
vite fait un enfant peut le faire elle
apparaît quand même car tout le monde se
le faire de toute façon quand les
enfants tout le monde mange la purée
alors de lui de livres du persil
delahaye laborieux où était quand même
pas compliqué on mélange le tout en face
au fou et ça y est et à l'autre qu'on a
mis dans son plat est lassé de la morue
mégalithes et édite des profs de persil
ou là
les cannoises un autre mangani
cathodique tour depuis mais il ne
connaîtra dans laquelle on a vu beaucoup
de piment d'espelette et que vous croyez
que ça soit un petit peu d'air bien des
attentions médina il ya une différence
majeure c'est que celle là vous aviez
laissé la peau oui et là on l'avait
enlevée alors ça n'a pas l'air mauvais
non plus et c'est au fond très facile
aussi c'est très facile parce qu'on fait
comme une espèce de piperade oui et puis
ça y est la morue et puis dessus combien
cinq minutes l'amour il sait tout et ça
y est voilà mais ya mille autre manière
de faire la morue olala oui vous avez la
morue grillée vous avez les beignets
vous avez mis le sorte de permis de
sorte mais aussi sorte de 36 à 20 ans
pourra peut-être la matière commencer un
autre jour alors mais avec plaisir mais
pour aujourd'hui les deux plates et bien
facile les deux plats ne sont pas chères
tout le monde peut les faire et dites
nous revoir et c'est très beau rallye
chantons à tout et régale boeuf à
bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]